eröffnen zu dürfen schon lange jetzt
frage ich die deutsche corona politik
nicht mehr das wissen die stammzuschauer
die regelung werden immer abstruser die
begründungen immer dürftiger gestern
erreichte mich dann die nachricht einer
besorgten mutter ihre tochter habe ein
so genannten denkt bretter von der
lehrerin erhalten ich zeige ihm hier
auch mal in die kamera die erste frage
auf dem briefbogen mastracchio falsch
gemacht die zweite frage folgende regel
habe ich nicht eingehalten ich habe
nicht immer meine maske auf gehabt der
denkzettel endet mit der frage was
nimmst du dir für die nächste zeit vor
die einfahrt des kleinen mädchens ich
werde jetzt immer meine maske aufsetzt
die schriftliche benachrichtigung muss
von den eltern unterzeichnet werden ich
habe selbst keine kinder aber ich
wünsche mir für unser land viele eltern
die denkzettel dieser art nicht
akzeptieren die nicht akzeptieren wenn
kinder vielleicht mal beim spielen kurz
vergessen ihre maske nicht auf zu setzen
solche art denkzettel mit nach hause
bekommen ja ich habe diesen denkzettel
dann auch im internet gesehen ich dachte
erst gute photoshop arbeit so was kann
es eigentlich nicht geben man sieht ja
oft irgendwelche erklärungen die amtlich
daher kommen da macht sich einen spaß
daraus und seine verschwörungs mythen zu
züchten das ist offenbar authentisch das
ist authentisch und das ist leider die
rückkehr einer eigenschaft eine haltung
die wir überwunden glaubt nämlich der
schwarzen pädagogik das sind also
kindern angst macht dass man ihnen ein
falsches verhalten vorwirft das ist ein
richtiges verhalten mit hohen
moralischen druck ich möchte schon sagen
adressiert an sie also interessiert sie
dressiert gewissermaßen zu einem
richtigen verhalten das finde ich sehr
sehr bedauerlich und das zeigt eben dass
wir aus einem politischen virus auch
eine politische verhaltens lehre gemacht
haben ich würde sagen eine verhaltens
lehre der kälte und ich kann nur sagen
ein großes wort das wir im munde führen
das heißt zivilcourage oft sagen wir
dass und wissen gleich so recht was wir
meinen ich glaube hier wird wirklich
zivilcourage gefordert dass wir sagen
also ich lasse meine kinder nicht so
abrichten und ich bin auch nicht bereit
meine kinder so ablichten zu lassen wir
sagen sonst immer mündiger bürger müssen
entstehen ich glaube wenn man solche
öffentliche bus und besserung rituale
macht entsteht ein untertan und kein
mündiger bürger unter brauchen mündige
bürger ich finde das spannend dass es ja
gar keine verordnung oder kein gesetz
gibt das schulen vorschreibt dass sie
solche denkzettel zu verteilen haben
sondern sie kommen von alleine auf die
idee ich glaube ehrlich gesagt aber
nicht dass es ganz von alleine kommt
sondern das ist schon die also man macht
er aus politischer rhetorik macht man
gelebte realität und was wir in den
vergangenen zwei jahren erlebt haben
zunächst relativ lange unter der
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel und
kanzleramtschef helge braun die ja
formal gar nicht zu bestimmen hatten was
in unseren schulen los ist aber wir
haben eine wie ich sage nur die
kinderfeindliche politik erlebt da wurde
angst geschürt da wurde immer wieder
gesagt dass kinder anstecken sind dass
man kinder beschützen muss dass kinder
auch ihre großeltern beschützen müssen
christian drosten hat das damals in
einer viele umstrittenen studie auch
einmal davor gewarnt schulen zu öffnen
und ich glaube das spiegelt sich dann
wieder in solchen handlungen die dann
nicht von oben verordnet wurden aber man
hat das was zwischen den zeilen durch
kann dann doch ganz gut folgen aber ich
sage ich noch schlimmer dann wenn es gar
keine anweisung mehr bleibt uns menschen
verinnerlichen weil sie meinen sie
machen eine staatsbürgerliche wertvolles
werk ja ich kann man das lehrerbild
tiefer hängen ich meine jetzt haben sie
einen titel von einer lehrerin
im moment ich habe vergessen auch auf
twitter geteilten denkt seite man musste
übrigens die erwähne ich habe ja mit der
mutter ausgewählt geschrieben von dem
mädchen das ihn bekommen hat und sie hat
gesagt eigentlich versteht sie sich auch
sehr gut mit der lehrerin also dass sie
hätte sie jetzt gewundert aber die
lehrerin wir eigentlich gut aber es hat
twitter kommentare geregnet harry von
müttern von vätern aber auch von
erwachsenen die erzählen was sie
eigentlich gerade
erleben und beispielsweise war einst
weder kommentar ich kann natürlich nicht
jedem dieser twitter kommentare
überprüfen wir nehmen jetzt einfach mal
an dass die menschen dort auf twitter
die wahrheit sagen mein sohn hat zwei
wochen eine 4 bekommen und eintrag ins
hausaufgabenheft weil er die maske im
unterricht zweimal abgenommen hat dann
gab es andere kommentare wo ein junger
geschrieben hat bei mir haben meine
eltern also in einer aus der oberstufe
mir haben die eltern gar nichts mehr
bekommen wir wurden einfach von der
schule abgeholt und deswegen ich glaube
schon dass dieser denkzettel
wir haben es hier natürlich nur ein
zugespielt bekommen aber dass diese
regelung der maske im unterricht zu
tragen und dann der maßregelung der
schüler ich glaube schon dass er an
mehreren schulen einzug gehalten hat
wenn ich mir die später kommentare
gestern durchgelesen habe am ursprung
steht auch eine regierung die erst mal
entscheidet kinder müssen masken tragen
und dann sind so lehrer die sind
möglicherweise auch mit so einer sache
überfordert weil es ja gar nicht so
leicht ist auch kindern zu erklären
diese maske ist ja auch mir so
wahnsinnig lästig wie nur was
ich habe immer das gefühl ich rate
meinen eigenen schlechten ein und wenn
ich knoblauch am vorabend gegessen habe
dann ist es wirklich mörderisch und
insofern ich habe ein es ist mühsam ich
bin völlig ihrer meinung ja aber ich
frage mich immer ob man nicht mit dem
urteil über die einzelnen menschen und
auch ihr fehlverhalten oder auch ihre
überreaktionen etwas zu hart ist in
angesicht möglicherweise eines kurses
den man kritisieren muss das ist einfach
sie sind historiker sie schauen ja gerne
dann ob es aufs große ganze wenn sie und
die deutsche schulpolitik die die
kinderpolitik sehen und hier wurden dort
kinder ja immer in den fokus der debatte
gestellt hier wurden schulen viel länger
geschlossen als in anderen ländern wie
ordnen sie das ein warum gerade in
deutschland also ich habe mich in meinem
leben lang als journalist mit geschichte
beschäftigt und kann mit historikern in
meinen themen auf einer augenhöhe
diskutieren ich bin kein historiker aber
das macht gar nichts wenn ich auf die
sache schaue
ob der fehler von der regierung gemacht
wurden oder nicht das können sie
wesentlich besser beurteilen als ich und
natürlich wünscht sich jeder dass man
den kindern ihre freiheit zurückgibt
dass die ohne masken in den schulklassen
auch bei geschlossenen fenstern bei den
temperaturen sitzen können das ist
völlig klar und dagegen kann man
argumentieren ich finde bloß dass die
einzelnen mit all diesen anforderungen
manchmal es einfach überfordert sind
auch busfahrer oder vor allem auch ich
sag mal restaurantbesitzer ich selber
habe das erlebt dass ich mit einem
freund in einem restaurant kam er war
nicht geimpft ich war geimpften wir
mussten gegen wieder obwohl es eine
beize war wie wir in bayern sagen dazu
in die wir seit 50 jahren gehen und das
ist dem wird doch auch nicht leicht
gefallen aber ist das nicht dass das das
portal dass der staat selbst nicht in
der lage ist seine regeln zu überprüfen
und sie die kontrolle deshalb den
bürgern überträgt den wirken den lehrern
den busfahrern dass sie sich um masken
pflicht und impft nachweise kümmern
finde ich nicht so fatal weil ich wusste
nicht wie sie das anders umsetzbar sein
soll also wenn man teil könnte man sagen
einfach gar nicht vielleicht ja ich
übrigens regel nicht verkehrt auf ich
bin sehr bei ihnen über die regeln und
die und die notwendigkeit könnten wir
wahrscheinlich stundenlang telefonieren
das gut diskutieren ja aber aber dass
die einzelnen davor recht schwierige
herausforderungen gestellt werden und
wissen sie wenn die polizei in bayern
zum beispiel sich ein wird greift der
leute bei sich sitzen hat die
beispielsweise nicht geimpft sind oder
am falschen impfnachweis gebracht haben
und nicht der ausweis übereinstimmen der
macht sein laden zu aber hier geht es ja
nicht um befolgung von regeln sondern
hat er einen ganz hohen moralischen
überschuss und das finde ich einfach so
bedenklich dass man einfach nicht in
einen kleinen jungen oder mädchen sagt
hör mal so und so ist es dann müssen wir
irgendwie umgehen dass wir die zu
erklären sollen dass das wirklich in die
ecke gestellt wird es wirklich
gewissermaßen mit der frisch geboren
schämen für ein fehlverhalten er hat
gewissermaßen schande über die
klassengemeinschaft gebracht also das
finde ich einfach viel zu hart und denkt
sein das hat er was von kopflos also man
gibt ja kleinkindern kopfnüsse habe ich
schon mal ein stichwort schon eben das
ist schwarze pädagogik das hat im 1
zwanzigsten jahrhundert nichts verloren
wir hätten letztes ja auch einen tollen
fall darum haben wir auch bei bild
berichtet er wurde in einem berufskolleg
den den den erwachsenen schülern dort
mit gegeben dass sie bitte nutzen schals
jacken mitbringen wenn sie mögen auch
decken er um die kälte im klassenraum
aus zu ertragen das ist mir glaube ich
dass inter ein klassenzimmer jetzt ja
auch bei bild genannt ich muss auch
sagen ich wäre hier auch bei philipp ist
mir auch gar nicht so weit gehen müsste
als lehrer aber wie wenn sie es
einschätzen frau navidi unsere
diskussion wenn wir davon ausgehen dass
wir alle mündige bürger sind dann würde
ich sagen muss jeder die motivation
haben dazu beizutragen zur bekämpfung
der pandemie
denn wir können sie nur als kollektiv
bewältigen und ich bin auch bei herrn
remy dass ich denke dass lehrer manchmal
überfordert sind es ist sicherlich nicht
einfach eine klasse von kleinkindern die
sehr lebendig sind da irgendwie sagt man
in zaum zu halten und in amerika haben
wir das gleiche problem mit den kindern
auch und auch immer das jetzt gerade wo
me com kommt was ja extrem ansteckend
ist dass dann die schulen das hat sich
so verbreitet dass die schule im
endeffekt wieder zugemacht werden musste
und dass viele lehrer auch selbst angst
hatten krank zu werden oder dass nach
hause zu bringen also ich glaube wir
sollten anstatt auch hart dann mit den
lehrern zu urteilen auch mehr
verständnis für die anderen aufbringen
ich muss sagen ich habe ein bisschen mit
der lehrer gemeinschaft natürlich kenne
ich persönlich jetzt nicht hunderte oder
tausende lehrer lehrer jeder lehrer
sieht das ja auch sicher unterschiedlich
aber was ich von den lehrerverbänden und
gewerkschaften mitbekommen habe war ganz
oft er der ton lasst uns lieber im
zweifel dichtmachen im zweifel die
schule schließen das konnte ich am
anfang der pandemie noch nachvollziehen
im laufe der pandemie im ersten herbst
habe ich mir gedacht na ja man weiß
mittlerweile dass kinder nicht so
ansteckend sind und selbst auch nicht
gefährdet sind und die lehrer können ja
auch maske tragen und lüften und aber es
ist spätestens seit der impfung habe ich
überhaupt kein verständnis dafür weil
jeder lehrer der möchte kann sich
doppelt und dreifach bald vielleicht
sogar vierfach impfung ist dann bestens
vor dem virus geschützt und dann hatte
er glaube ich seine arbeit nachzugehen
und seine arbeit ist eigentlich mehr als
normale arbeit ist einberufung dass es
heißt kinder zu auch mit zu erziehen
kindern wissen mitzubringen aus kindern
mündige bürger zu machen und dann im
zweifel in die schulen zu zu machen
ich habe mein amerika genau das gleiche
problem wo in chicago lehrer gesagt
haben wir weigern uns jetzt physischen
unterricht zu machen ich glaube dass
zwei drei wochen her und so die
regierung gesagt hat ihr müsst jetzt in
die schule gehen sonst werdet ihr nicht
bezahlt und den new york hatten wir den
fall dass hunderte schüler aus den
schulen gegangen sind sie wollten
wiederum einen fernunterricht haben also
ich glaube um ikon ist ja trotzdem noch
sehr ansteckend der sehen immer noch
dramatische fälle und ich glaube auch
die ängste der menschen müssen wir ernst
nehmen und da jetzt brachial durch zu
reagieren und sagen okay ich bin jetzt
ich bin stark ich kann das risiko tragen
es gibt aber menschen die das eben nicht
sind und ich würde denen er mit
verständnis begegnen aber ich würde eben
gerade so eine ansprache brachial das
finde ich brachial dass man wirklich
gewissermaßen einen bogen einen zensuren
bogen verteilt und da sollten der oder
diejenige sein schlechtes verhalten
eingestehen ich finde das muss man
wirklich kommunikativ gestehen man kann
auch mit kindern reden aber der als haus
dem kind als hausaufgabe das mit zu
geben da muss die mutter noch
unterzeichnen dass das kind
gewissermaßen moralisch gefehlt hat das
finde ich nicht wir haben ja auch andere
fälle zum beispiel der amerika wärme zum
beispiel auch england ich war am
wochenende in england da ist die masken
pflicht komplett beck ich musste selbst
am flughafen keine masken tragen auch
nicht bei der passagierkontrolle mehr
ich habe gar keine maske getragen ganze
wochenende lang und es war dort auch
völlig normal
der durfte jeder mensch einfach selber
entscheiden wie er sich weiter manche
menschen nochmals gegen tragen andere
nicht michaela sehr berührt dass
plötzlich wieder die individuell
entscheidung einen berg hatte weil weder
die mit maske wurden komisch angeguckt
im supermarkt in london noch die ohne
dänemark hat ja heute auch die maßnahmen
fallen lassen